come see our live stream
momenthouse.com
trash tuesday that is coming up very
soon and it's going to be chaotic and
ruin our lives so we'll see you there
march 30th at 6 p.m pacific right yeah 6
p.m pacific
momenthouse.com trash tuesday let's go
let's burn
oh hey annie
hey girl
so we do stand-up comedy and we get to
meet our slugs and it's so much fun it's
been more fun than you can imagine it's
like
you're officially in the slug club when
we yeah in greece life affirming this
weekend this very weekend i'm returning
to the midwest i'm so excited i'm going
to be in indianapolis please come out
and after that philly san diego austin
brooklyn dc chicago get tickets at
esteronice.com and annie what's going on
with you
well guys i'm going to be in vegas this
weekend i'm going to freak out but
that's going to be next week it's going
to be so fun i can't wait then i'll be
in san francisco syracuse new york
florida burbank california that'll be
fun um austin texas
arizona michigan i have a million dates
go to my website anneliderman.com shows
and we of course want you to watch
todd's show on netflix making fun and
why not watch doll face if you haven't
watched doll face yet go binge it it
will go by like that and you will have
so much fun okay i'll do it if you guys
do it
if you have so you have to do it
[Music]
what's going on what's going on what so
what was in the car
my lipstick oh but i have a present for
you guys my present came in for you
really i just want you to know i'm
always thinking about you
okay
when
something
when i see anything i snatch it okay
so
these are i think maybe we should wear
these on the
is a lives bag okay who wants to open it
wait do you guys this is uh this is very
important because we should match
obviously this is gonna be awkward for a
moment but do you guys know that
today is my birthday
has it been the year since your
quinceanera
you're getting over the trauma of your
last birthday today is my bro where's
your wheelchair
we need to go to the wheelchair that we
had to cgi out
i don't know if this is the worst
producing or the best producing ever but
you guys not knowing that today is my
birthday episode is amazing does it make
you feel good kind of i feel like i
we've moved on from friendship into like
true
companionship in a job
wait what does that mean like it's not
like the uh the
the scariness of like needy friends
right like uh a real loving look it's
like lovers no no no we're 10 years into
a companion companionate relationship
where it's like you know what i don't
even know when we got together when our
anniversary is but it's sort of
somewhere sometime in february every day
feels like our birthday or our
anniversary i sort of think it's that
but more so i know that i have the
personality of someone who would be
obsessed with their birthday but i truly
am not and i don't care like i doesn't
that sound like someone who's lying
about not caring i don't care it looks
like she was saying it in the mirror
just saying you mean to say we threw you
that quinceanera last year for nothing
yes
no that was the funniest part you didn't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] that was for you
guys
we have to do it we're doing an esther
episode birthday episode again but you
look you manifested you gave you're
giving me a gift because i'm codepen i
get presents for people all day so i
don't need a birthday in this
relationship every day maybe we should
have you wear all three
annie you know we have to get a tattoo
of her name like today i have no tattoos
and if you think the first tattoo's
gonna be esther you're [ __ ] crazy
that's where you're wrong
oh my god i'm so excited i was crying
when i saw these don't read what it is
don't okay just open it okay because
there's two each person gets two pieces
okay oh my god should i
actually want you to open first so the
bigger the bigger piece i want you to
open first
i want you to open this one first okay
there's a medium for me too small feliz
cumpleanos
[Laughter]
oh so this is my birthday present and
you're actually short
and then i thought because that's just
crude that you guys could have
i wanted you to be covered up i got you
these really big
kim kardashian
west or not west because she's divorced
today but
you nailed it
these are the women of today what are
they for who are there these are that
tiny
this is for us
last week
my legs would absolutely fly out of
those there's no part to hold them yeah
i don't even think
like this does have the tag on it i
don't know is this supposed to be the
back this is what happened remember my
christmas outfit was like
a splitter
should i yes okay
it really am the birthday girl
happy birthday esther
the real birthday present is you giving
one of these to kawhila
and then you giving her one
this is so
like what did she make these for so
uncomfortable who are they for this is
so sexual
this is the opposite of a well this is
wait do you wear that under or over you
wear it under
wait maybe yeah but it's okay
it's the same [ __ ] thing
oh my god
oh we all have matching ones
i don't know what size those are should
i put them on
yeah maybe we'll put them on all of us
let's pitch up to making these outfits
this is so good what are they for it's
like [ __ ] you have a surrogate why are
you trying to get people pregnant
[Laughter]
well don't you kind of feel like skims
is replacing
the whole that was left in our hearts
when victoria's secret kind of died out
um
yeah but victoria's secret was more is
more like really like do you see my
turquoise swear that's victoria's secret
you know what i mean it's like a little
cheesy it's definitely from the mall
yeah damn that is i just realized that
the worst insult you can give someone is
to compare them to turquoise jewelry
wait is victoria's secret chugi
it must be
i no it's so well they're they kind of
were cancelled because like they were
basically the founders of making us all
anorexic and [ __ ] assad they swung
the other way and now they have a
a model with downs yeah but are we gonna
forget
what they did to us for the last 20
years they're really i mean that's a
hard swing they're like we're putting
special needs people in or like oh yeah
wait a second it's like that's not who
you guys are she's also a very skinny
she's hot she's beautiful but i i just
don't like how they have to announce it
so
explicitly just put her on there without
having to congratulate yourself how
about that no i know that's i totally
agree what world are these four like
what are these four
there are four this
[ __ ] cast they're for getting [ __ ]
instantly what is this
but
i can understand the underwear that
barely covers
like that is pretty hot wait hang on
it's you know what with the micro thong
yes i know the name of the product
were you always wanting one but like
scared to get one maybe bust out
i actually have the worst news ever i
already have the microphone in that
color yes and i but i never we like i
haven't worn it because i
i just i was thinking about getting
different colors no i love this that's
just i was like maybe someone will wear
this for real you know what's really
good about this
is that if um gravity has sort of
dropped your ass just ever so slightly
this brings it back up look
at this part and if prove it if god
bore you with a dropped vagina oh my god
look at her ass okay that is hot as [ __ ]
but it brings it back up because this is
not what my ass usually says that
picture
i i was talking about i told dave about
it i was talking about it i think carlos
and i talked about it again lately i
honestly think that we should get an
only fans and that's the only picture we
post i'm the only fan does it come on my
back but people but but you have to you
have to be an only fans member for
two years before you release it like we
need to know your loyalty you don't get
to just have it i don't even know whose
nut that was i mean that is
that's how long i don't know i'm not
gonna lie knowing your history and what
i saw i think it's who's nuts those are
because
that came from all directions
that was a communal level
oh my god i'm never gonna have a gang
bang again that's okay again
well i never had i had like some multi
multiple enjoyments am i the only like
am i the prudest person in the world
because you guys have dated multiple
people you've had a threesome with one
of our mutual friends now you're telling
me you've been gangbanging here let me
tell you why no let me tell you what was
the exaggeration let me tell you what
jack johnson the singer songwriter once
said don't like was he coming on your
back
he certainly was as he was skeeting on
who came to talk about they ski
he said don't let your dreams be dream
sister so if a gang bang is what you
want a gang bang is what you're gonna
have to get the audience is going that's
our dream
wait can we go back to victoria's secret
for a second because you know that they
have like a it's like a scary past that
carlos will you look this up the
victoria's secret original founder do
you guys know this story that he sold
the company for like x amount of money
and then it became way bigger and he
killed himself
yeah i was in the social network yeah
and it's and it's the same thing that
kate with kate himself with the song
did kate spade sell early on yes and
then it became way bigger and then she
ended up hanging like killing herself
it's it this is like a thing what
happened to the founder victoria's
secret uh ended his life by jumping off
the golden gate bridge yeah because
it's really weird like people who sell
their companies and then they become
more successful like it doesn't they
can't handle it i just believe lightning
can strike twice and i do think if you
can have an idea that's so good i do
think you can have another one i agree i
hate the people because your brain
even though these people took it maybe
marketed it differently and that's what
sold it learn from what they did
differently from you and apply that to
your next
but there are people that are just
really magical idea churners yeah
they're people that can just like roll
it out every day and um you know you're
right i think that maybe he
underestimated his own you know
potential for that because like how big
did it get and the name victoria's
secret
initially like think about it when you
it is a cheesiest
but so catchy yeah
but i i agree with your point like
whenever i hear someone
that's like oh i [ __ ] this thing up
but i had what i always try to tell them
like you're a renewable resource like
you will have another idea you will have
you know another whatever
are you like peeling their underwear
down while you're saying
like oh you're sad let me tell you
something let me build you up um
but yeah i i don't know i'm always
fascinated by like those kind of
business things and also victoria's
secret like i wonder if it was just
ill-fated from the start like
i just can't believe it's your birthday
yeah maybe who knows but it is cheesy
you're right it's like that guy had like
the cheesiest yeah it's it's like a
white guy who's like victorious yeah
what the hell were you imagining for you
yeah imagine calling something annie's
secret that's i've never had a secret in
my life
if i have a secret no one told me
i can't believe so i came in and just in
western wear for fun didn't tell anyone
and then this was sitting next to me
you guys are really starting to tap it
there you go i'm telling you i let go of
attachments and now
and now there's a fire and now we're
psychically
oh it's your birthday
these are fast fashion clothes so they
are highly flammable are you um
is this did you think like that's my
birthday is my birthday outfit they're
gonna have so much stuff yeah yes i want
to dress like carlos asked me that too
no i'm just trying to up my game and
like be a normal girl who buys normal
girl clothes do you know where i think
you can really draw a real inspiration
from if you look at ajummas like old
korean ajimos like grandmas they're the
pioneers of power clashing
i think that
what you're striving for is ultimately
what the ajummah fashion korean
grandmothers yes korean grandmothers
emphasis on the grandmother i oh i'm
aware it's like a mix of like street
wear comfort but also big fashion
like high fashion
we should give esther pre-period in
pants too
what do you mean just so the period
stain's already there so you don't have
to like worry about it or don't feel bad
about it yeah yeah is that a trash tank
idea we sell our merch has period stains
we should maybe have already sweaty
armpits dude annie will you please touch
my armpit should we let's draw wetness
under the armpits
that is that's genius on gray shirts yes
i want blood spots on the lower butt oh
she's like is that working right now how
far we've come
when you're scared of it
is that where you usually get the stain
yeah wow that far back it's usually
really low like down here oh show us
again show us where it is i'll never
stop showing look how flexible she is we
could really bend her around
oh you might get your birthday bang
your birthday's going to end with a
gangbang
all right i have cupcakes for esther and
the gang this is the game is this from
sprinkles yeah vegan and you can light
it with your gun lighter too
this is so
well the exciting got come on there you
go there you go
it's like a torch i love this gun
thank you oh there's number one i don't
know why i thought they're thank you
oh i'm strawberry it's nice to know what
you guys think of us
lucky what did you get no i'm just a
being in it's so fake you put an f for
fake vegan
i could put meat in your mouth right now
i could [ __ ] put anything in your
mouth right now
it is i wonder if we make kalila's
vaginal crust jerky would that be
considered vegan
it would be like
bonito flakes on top of sushi
flakes
it just
yeah it's just um discharge flicks
this actually looks like my discharge
that's so funny you come in and get the
keys oh my god eat it [ __ ] i know what
you're about to do wait are we you wait
we came up with an annie no listen
i'm not attached i'm not attached you're
supposed this was the deal that we made
you're supposed to wait
to see how much i eat okay right and
then you follow okay because once you go
for it then you're gonna be mad at me
i'm gonna control you i'm trying to
control wait talk to me like that i like
that
no you get yelled at or loved you don't
get any in between tell me
[Music]
pewdiepie you get either reprimanded or
encouraged no but the way she just
talked to you was like
a dog i liked it
it was like no you learned
what speaking that that's why you like
it
you're the og puppy girl have you guys
heard of puppy girls
she's [ __ ] what's the name jake yeah
jacob now now it's interesting i thought
we were on that
you've been a trendsetter since the age
of eight jacob the dog is now a thing
adults do is that really true what do
you mean can you pull it up carlos puppy
girls there we are not jacob the dog
you're watching kalyala i'm just
watching kala slowly peel it and hoping
that's so she can actually take a bite
and not to kind of distract herself oh
you're so mentally ill from under
some icing
okay banana flavor is so mature of you
okay we can get rid of the cupcakes too
if we need like discipline help with not
eating oh my god
no i feel good about that it's the only
reason
i'm okay but oh yeah i'm having some of
the cupcake all right annie you're done
actually i do have gum if you guys have
any cravings for the rest i do have this
goop sweet kick gum that'll get rid of
your craving yeah from gwyneth from
gwyneth's vagina it better tastes like
her [ __ ]
wait so this is the gum that makes sweet
things taste bad
annie you're the guinea pig
i knew there were some tricks this is
carlos is like healthy you guys they're
trying to be slick listen they're trying
to be what is
it that's the equivalent of like chewing
something and spitting it out without
swallowing goop sells this
yeah twenty dollars for a bunch wait a
second i thought this was like a prank
thing not like a try to help you listen
such a disordery thing i know it is
that's okay we're just exploring it's
carlos you're really bad harlow
can i just tell you something carlos
lives off of those sushi the seaweed the
seaweed
paper
yeah from trader joe's that's what
carlos eats so we have a real anorexic
in the crew
listen there's
eating disorders exist we're exploring
[Laughter]
wait they're not
gum you've been into it so hard did you
lose a tooth there's directions on the
back no no there aren't
and you're the direction reader
that is your official title
what does the box say your tooth okay i
heard that it's okay i don't know if i'm
sucking on the thing or the tooth
pop a mint step one pop a mint when
sugar cravings strike
step two let it fully dissolve
step three
beat carlos to death block sweetness to
help control your sugar cravings annie
this is psychotic i'm so excited give me
one this is the coolest thing wait but
do we know how long it lasts you can't
eat it after you've already had sugar
no no i'm gonna take another bite
afterwards just one
i don't know what to do because how long
does it last i don't think it lasts that
long because there's so many i'm like
why would they give you a million if
they're like that's worth watching
what's your that's my answer what's your
worst case scenario also he's never
gonna have the right answer she's just
gonna answer yeah the thing with carlos
is he just does will say a thing no this
is a thing that men do and it drives me
crazy it's like this is not about carlos
it's a guesstimate
no do you guys notice that men do this
they will not say they don't know
something and they give a lot they lie
because they're scared to say i don't
know what is this made of what are the
active ingredients
you could just suck on it's like stevia
something is doing something silent
because like monk fruit is like uh or
even caffeine is uh appetite suppressant
no it's amazing
taste buds
oh i'm really excited about this carlos
what's in it hold up i'm looking it up
instead of laughing you're giving it did
you say we even said what hold up just
get it always answers you it's not good
you could just get covered wait what's
not good the way i answer because you
just you give answers there's no thought
you just you silence her
careful oh my god i'm being silenced at
home you're being silenced by a scary
man
a scary big sugary man that eats seaweed
it suppresses the taste of this is the
type of stuff we should 100 be done yeah
this is crazy i know
i don't co-sign this i'm gonna try it
and then i'll see if i co-sign it but
also i think we can just like decide all
right the other stuff by means in
chromium all that stuff is just like you
know is it out of your mouth is it done
it's still there she's still sucking on
her tooth
[Music]
mental health is
the most important thing we have a
really good conversation about mental
health on today's show like and getting
better
yeah working on yourself but you have to
you need
i would say 99 of the time you need the
assistant of someone
that knows what is going on in your
psyche yeah you can't do it alone right
someone who's unbiased someone who isn't
your friend or a family member because
you know it can be heavy on them too so
what better way to sound off to that
fault like a personal attack
stopped let's just say stopped receiving
my facetimes a little while ago
what we're saying is we want you to
check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday because better help is a
better way to get therapy you do it at
home on you know just digitally and they
can't hang up on you like
some people can it is so convenient you
can start talking to a therapist in
under 48 hours they have a really cool
journal feature that i love where if i'm
not seeing my therapist for another six
days and if i'm feeling my feelings
extra hard that day then i can just jot
them down and then bring it up when i
see her i think the most important
factor for me is that like
you do it from home you don't have to
drive somewhere you don't have to find
parking you don't have to sit in the
waiting room next to annie
you
do it at home that's how codependent i
am i turn even her therapy sessions into
couple therapy
it's affordable it's more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and um
you need to do this like you need to get
help in fact you don't even need to see
them face to face if you don't want to
when i'm having extra difficult days
where i'm in the dark and i cannot crawl
out of my bed to pick up my computer i
just talk on the phone
and it's that it's that simple it's that
convenient sometimes i can't i'm so
self-aware that while i'm in the therapy
session i'm like the therapist can tell
that i'm only looking at my own screen
right i'm like fixing my hair i'm like
oh no they can tell
you guys we want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health including us again that's
betterhelphelp.com
trash tuesday and i can promise you this
show would not survive if we weren't all
working on our mental health
consistently listen guys you know i like
to spend money but i there are certain
areas in my life where i did not know i
was leaking cash i mean leading cash out
of my ripping out dripping and true bill
thank you so much
i needed that rude awakening i i'm
saving so much money now look i didn't
know that i was subscribed to an anime
streaming site for four straight years i
could have guessed
i do love anime it wasn't even me who
subscribed i remember just wanting like
wanting my my niece was like oh i want
to watch um demon slayer and i was like
yeah sure you know
esther with the with a hard enough
stroke everything can be pornography
okay you gotta focus and then four years
after i've just completely forgotten
that i've been paying this monthly and
i'll do the things to where i'll pay for
the year and then you don't yeah it's
like oh it's just a little chunk the
fourth year i'm like oh my god i spent
three hundred dollars and companies make
it really hard to unsubscribe or cancel
yourself oh it's hidden somewhere in my
phone i don't even know how to
unsubscribe at this point it's almost
going through true it's trickery but if
you don't know what we're talking about
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need or
want or you just simply forgot about and
on average people save up to seven
hundred and twenty dollars a year i
think
a one and a half celine glasses
because companies make subscriptions
hard to cancel true bill makes it
incredibly simple just link your
accounts and trouba will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap it's
so easy and your true bill concierge is
there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to there's a concierge it's so good you
guys know how the the rude awakening it
is when you realize that your
ex-boyfriend from three boyfriends ago
is still on your hulu account
that hurts i'm like i was wondering why
they were looking up uh
annie's e-show
you know what app i had for two years
that i didn't know that i was paying for
an insect finder what an insect
identifier well it's right there i got
it right there it's an ester
scalp you guys don't fall for
subscription scams start canceling today
at truebill.com trash tuesday go right
now truebill.com trash tuesday it could
literally save you thousands a year
[Music]
but i'm realizing like how you just
can't get new teeth like i'm just
realizing this now like
the lesson of your parents being like
floss and brush you look sad this is the
wrong person
i was just thinking like how i hate the
when people i they can get them if they
want i don't judge them for getting it
but i don't like the veneers the horse
teeth i don't like the i don't like how
they look and i also i know they're like
a sign of wealth i feel like is what
they are at this point they still are
ugly like a louis vuitton bag i agree
with you that i think a little bit of a
[ __ ] up tooth is better than like the
fake perfect ones i'll take it one
step further i think veneers are choogy
they're weird and you can't undo
what's another word for chugi because i
feel like we should be ahead of joogie
kind of like maybe just out of style a
bit yeah but it's just the fact that
they're permanent and i've never seen
some more where i go that looks better
unless maybe they had like really [ __ ]
up teeth but usually it's just like oh
my god that was part of your like flavor
that was like part of who you are i like
using old [ __ ] as an adjective and not
a noun like that's old [ __ ] of you okay
i like that yeah i think the greatest
thing that have ever happened to me is
because i got braces really young i love
your teeth but so when i took my braces
off my teeth started to separate because
my jaw was still growing because you're
blowing so many guys right
and so
i could really floss with a micro penis
micropenis
i mean story not joke story um but the
greatest thing that ever happened was i
got my gaps back and i i really that's
like one of my favorite parts about my
body it's so cute i love gaps i
davidson got rid of his gap i'm like
pete
yes he's got the things i love gabs
madonna it makes me so sad wait madonna
did yeah
i remember that it's so hot as i get
more money people get like
rich and they like get more basic and
more basic and more basic i feel like
yeah
is there a thrill to like achieve
you know a certain like well i guess
because it's like perfection and would
everyone would look the same yeah
whatever but
why would you change your teeth but then
i'm like so and then when they they like
grind them down into nubs and for the
veneers yeah
like think of if your boobs like hadn't
come out like couldn't come out and you
just would have had to have two little
what the [ __ ] what are you saying
cosmetic surgery if she had grinded her
boobs down before yeah if they had had
to do that for her why even go there
oh look at you now
that's why look at your face look at
your reaction that's exactly what esther
do you not have any more urges to be a
dog
like if you bring it up like it's
certainly
possible for me and just for people who
don't know when i was little i
thought i was a dog named jacob
and i ate out of i would for a period of
time i would only eat out of a bowl on
the floor
and drink out of blood i like the idea
of your parents kind of like tripping
over you not noticing just completely
ignoring this behavior and i would bite
people i bit everyone but my mom
um
so that's like kind of the origin i met
a dog named how was it
it's better than it was before it's less
sweet
what it's less sweet it tastes [ __ ]
delicious
what do you mean
i think that's just supposed to curb
your like
wanting a sweet thing have another one
it
take this
collab
and it what it tastes perfect now so it
was it is less sweet though it's the
tiniest bit less sweet and makes it like
i want to eat more
oh no
this is like when the science experiment
goes wrong and like frankenstein has
more powers than he was supposed to
maybe it was maybe it was um maybe it's
we didn't do it right carlos carlos is
in charge i'm going to take a bite of my
cupcake so will you just monitor me and
come take it from me yeah just be cool
about it
enjoy it how about that yeah just enjoy
it enjoy your life
kalya's got the smallest bite out of her
new [ __ ]
are you kidding me look
this is why never work out with me once
because we'll be bound
i'm like we're now bound
that is so scary to say that's a threat
i am threatening
eat up [ __ ]
oh it's so cute carlos help me
come get it
wait can i say something about my dog
right now because you're reminding me of
him
randy is the most popular boy in the
neighborhood and it's the joy of my life
he's working two more
carlos is her calorie coach a skinny
coach is that what they're called i
don't know what it is oh these basic
celebs were there
burger king
umami
and fat burger but they're all
impossible
okay
burgers
burger king
umami fat
take all the same
at the same time oh wait yes okay we're
gonna we're gonna start with burger king
okay burger king annie
why doesn't it have to take the bottom
bread off can you make them colder
it doesn't feel cold enough
where's like the toppings i got it plain
just to be cool that's not cool it's my
[ __ ] birthday and you got them
playing your toppings i love that her
birthday
putting food in her face
this is
this sucks man
he's
[Music]
okay but why is the bottom bread on
there still i hope this i hope these
calories don't go to your labia in those
underwear
okay the second one is what
okay we had to get a rating before we
move on to the next shut up
you are acting just like my little pup
don't anger our puppy girl on her
quinceanera carlos which one was that
one that one's really good fat burger
that one's the better one fat burger has
been in the past my favorite we could do
esther you're moving too fast through
this let's have a lettuce wrap next time
okay so uh i thought the burger king one
i'll give it a six
um this one i will i can't wait until i
taste the other ones
carlos is pouting in the corner no i'm
writing down the rating kalila just
kidding fat burger six
oh wait no you guys the fat burger one
is way better right
oh yeah
is that over there
a normal one
not impossible one
look at the minute
i took off one of the breads we saw
we were watching we were making sure
the third one is what
mommy burger i don't like that one mommy
was okay burger king was the least good
mommy was second i will say this about
the burger king there is a nostalgic
cheapness about the taste
i think if the burger king one
had
lettuce tomatoes
pickles onions
we could have a real conversation a real
dialogue
yeah but see the good thing about the
fat burger one is double stacked we
don't want your onion breath on your
birthday okay that's dude he's saving
you
if you think i don't already have onion
breath
i ate earlier
i am quietly enjoying this i'm in a
shame spiral what what just happened i
blacked out did i growl at anyone
you growled at me twice
spiral what did i do i blacked out
because there were impossible burgers i
want to formally apologize to the
producers in the room and to my co-hosts
all right this is out of control listen
um
you only lashed out at carlos don't
worry we all liked it it felt like my
birthday
we got randy this bone and he's just
vicious wait what is this about them we
went out for valentine's day we got this
like big steak we went to nobu
wait you did yeah
and we went no who has steak i thought
nobody was sushi no wait i went to the
other one what's the one next to it
steak and mouth i mean there's some
mcdonald's across the street no what's
this the fancy restaurant right on uh
prime ocean prime oh yeah
but we brought this big like this giant
bone back for the littlest dog in the
world and randy you know he's two teeth
on the bottom so he's like trying to get
at it and we just go near him he's like
it's like randy we brought this for you
[ __ ] like we want you to have this
you [ __ ] you're so mad but i did want to
say i have to brag about randy he is i
wanted the most popular dog in the
neighborhood and i got him when he goes
to the dog park people gasp
they go randy's here because he's so
prancey so cute he's a little reindeer
i'm so cute
some woman was like we should do like a
dog swap and i went
i'm not taking your [ __ ] shitty dogs
a dog swap where you get the king
no no wait people do that that's not a
thing that's absurd that's what people
pitch when they want to steal your dog
oh she's like i'd be so happy if he was
just like prancing around my house i go
yeah it's really great
she'll work on training your dogs to be
cuter
so what is a puppy girl
you're the pioneer you're the one who
started the movement is it like you tell
us is it a okay puppy girls the women
with a fetish for acting like her dog is
out a lot
wow you're the leader of this movement
esther puppy girl jenna earns ten
thousand dollars a month on only fans
making videos of herself playing fetch
begging for food and being taken on a
nice long walk guys we're getting some
only fans ideas and i know that we keep
pitching this only fans but we can do if
it's not like full [ __ ] labia [ __ ] we
can do it
you know what
she seems cool
[Laughter]
carlos is in love carlos bring her home
to us i don't like shane's always
follows her that's
you missed out on a great one
she's sucked up she subscribes to that
what is it sadomasochist what so she's a
sub so sado massac is submissive i'm
kind of sad she doesn't have more
followers only pause only pause is good
she's in the top .02 creators not only
fans i'm not gonna lie i feel like the
sexy puppy thing like i can't really
move on from that it looks pretty good
it's really like it's really sticking
with for your birthday
you get to choose we're gonna go to the
pet store after this and you get to
choose your own leash
and your own caller and annie and i are
going to walk you around town for your
birthday oh my god
harness oh yeah of course there's gonna
be a fake [ __ ] in the middle of it
though it's gonna go around your crotch
area
i want a man's perspective on this like
carlos you because you used to work at a
dog rescue like is this there's nothing
sexual about it to me really
yeah like a girl pretending to be a dog
is not you're like way to go theater
major
somebody didn't make their college play
and made a different turn
took a turn
literally me
esther's like i don't know
if i want to wait in trailers anymore i
might just start making my own content
i mean it i don't cast as a dog this is
a
like a solid
plan b for my life if things you know
let's make it a plan a today okay
plan ass
esther i saw you hanging out with your
queen idol maria menounos on instagram
yes i did her podcast she's amazing now
annie you commented
on the photo i posted with maria manuno
saying te what's the truth reveal the
true story and i literally
need you to remind me because i don't
remember we went to the grove together
back in the day and they used to shoot
extra live
she was the host of extra so it was her
and mario lopez
we're at the grove and we
wanted to
get her attention so obviously you made
me do it so we're like standing on the
edge and we're like we like your dog we
were just being the creepiest most
annoying people could she hear us she
responded to us we said thanks a little
bit like
that's so we fangirled like in the front
like we may as well been like outside
the today show
we were fangirling
i we were going into strike we wanted to
ask her her diet but we couldn't get
that glass the security intervened
well i finally met her for real where
you own all her you own her book yes
where did the love affair start her book
she had this book the every girl's guide
to life and it was just so like honest
and real and i really took to it
like she has such big sister energy that
i like fell in love with her and i'll
never forget the life tip in her book
that i still do it's like if you want to
like make your bathroom at home seem
like it's like nice and fancy ask carlos
to clean it that first and then roll up
get buy like a ton of cheap white
washcloths
fold them and roll them and like stack
them and then you have like a spa like
bathroom the amount of [ __ ] blood and
snot that are on those that you have to
really long off you do have to buy new
ones every few months
they stain quick
um but yeah then i did our podcast and
she was so nice and so cool we should
have her on this show and you guys
should do her show she's no she's so
cool and she's so like um
she's so sweet so iconic to me like
she's so beautiful and she's had such a
long interesting career
i don't know i just um i obviously been
in love with her
and weirdly me and her husband are like
like we're like the same person i feel
like she and dave are the same and me
and her husband you know how when you're
like hitting on someone you kind of want
to make up make friends with their like
spouse to make it cool esther will you
repeat that because i feel officially
offended and kind of jealous what do you
mean say what you just said
about her partner i'm like her husband
and she she's like dave uh-huh what so
you know how you identify with bobby so
i'm just
the lesser maria menounos no i'm just a
standard you have no idea who knows
that's crazy no no no you do you're onto
something you're right
she's maria manuela since she couldn't
have maria for a long time
she just said no no no no no no no no
you did you mean you you menuno's turner
no no no no but i do see a correlation
are you that you're more like dave and
i'm more like bobby i do see that that
that's a thing
gotta say i'm a little jealous
maybe we should bring her here and you
guys should fight for me
she does like to wrestle and also she
was the host of the um which i actually
was trying to get this job
i was screaming to nobody but i was like
i really want this job can someone get
it for me um the uh
the host of the real or the the
challenge uh after party the after show
mm-hmm
i love it yeah the mtv challenge is my
favorite show one of my favorite shows
and so she was the host this year and i
was like okay if it's if it can't be me
[Music]
here's the truth we don't mind hair we
like hair we just need you to groom it
up escape it once in a while a little
scaping
a little manscaping
i shaved my bush today
on the way in
i didn't even know it was esther's
birthday but i know
subconsciously you're back right listen
it's not the
company does not tell us to talk about
this but i don't care okay i'm breaking
free during this ad
todd and i we have his and hers and it
is the same one
ball trimmers okay
the lawnmower 4.0 the lawnmower 4.0 is
for this four-point hoe too okay i love
it i use we both use them they're great
todd's been using all the shampoos and
the body wash we're like slithering up
well also you can have really accurate
grooming sessions because they have that
led light and it's also waterproof so
you can take it in the shower with you
it comes in a little package it's got so
much stuff it's awesome i also love that
they just launched like actually men's
hair care
and it's really easy because it's a
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner which
you know guys are lazy and so are some
girls look do i love their shampoo yeah
sure steve bannon
and if a guy has tattoos or dry skin
manscaped has him covered with the
hydrating body moisturizer spray which
is really awesome dave has been using it
i have boyfriends the tattoos yours is
the crusty yeah
um he'll definitely want to use a
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer to clean
off any unwanted body hair and it's the
lawnmower 4.0 is our favorite product
it's waterproof and
it's a major key to the new shower room
also i think of manscape as like a
one-stop shop for um
men's self-love
you know what else we never talk about
is that it's a funny gift this is a
funny gift to give you guys especially
your father which we can go through this
again if you want no thank you um you
guys can get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code trash at manscaped.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code trash at
for your daughter's birthday i am gonna
buy you some landscapes so you look out
he already has plenty let's get the man
in your life nice and clean with a new
manscaped shower routine
can we talk about liquid death and how
it's blowing up and it's become the
coolest brand of water everywhere i know
i don't want to say it's because i got
on our podiums but you kind of do right
i want to say it
i saw it a lot before us well no i've
been getting tagged in so many
instagrams of people drinking it because
of us i feel like we started this trend
and i want to keep it going
um and you may have started to notice
that you see these weird tall boys that
look cans that look like beer they're
just water
and we love it so much because it makes
us feel cool i mean if i had this in
middle school i might not have been a
juvenile delinquent like if i point i
could have just felt because so much of
it was just looking cool yes this was
like
duels or something right or something to
hold
but let's also focus on like what's
really cool about them is they call it
liquid death because it's death to
plastic
i'm so sick of
just nasty water bottles that have been
sitting in the heat and all melty and
disgusting liquids stop talking about
kalila's old boob job okay
also correct
but also most most plastics are not even
recyclable
and that's crazy so the fact that now we
have delicious water and
awesome aluminum cans that make us look
like rock stars all day and it's a
conversation starter don't have don't be
drinking your
your plastic bottles and then they get
thrown into landfills then they end up
in the water kalaila's tried to
spearfist a fish she comes up with a
plastic don't do that to our girl okay
they also donate ten percent of the
profits from every can sold to help kill
plastic pollution like they're doing
god's work for us so we just get don't
you guys love the sound of when it
cracks open
well do you know what that sound i
always think about with that sound is
have you ever been when you're younger
you go to the movie theaters and your
dad makes you bring the soda from home
and so you everyone in the theater hears
you cracking open and then you like go
to get the popcorn and you put a hole in
the back all right
letterman
we get it
get free shipping on all water and merch
at liquiddeath.com
trash that's liquiddeth.com trash or
grab some at whole foods sprouts and
7-eleven
[Music]
by the way i found a solution so you
know how i don't like to have sex
without a bra i've found a solution to
that and it's sheer mesh bra oh i
thought you were gonna say doggy
can i see you can still see yeah
hot
i love that is that a negative it's a
negative yeah yeah
i did get horny i'm not gay but i did my
i got wet
down there
so i have nipple envy over your nipples
oh no
it really is my birthday huh i put a lot
of i put like a lot of padding on
because i knew i was gonna pit sweat
these so i had to counter the pits
the cutlets oh no i hate the feeling of
taking those off oh god
it's like a sticky for people who don't
know it you tape it to your tit and then
you have to peel it off your nipple it's
so
i had chicken cutlets fall off in the
dance floor ones
like slip from under me yeah
yeah they're slippy well they're yeah it
completely fell off from under me they
used to when i was go dancing they would
always come up when they'd be like your
thingy's showing like push it down
like up to my neck
are there songs that you guys listen to
where you think like oh this has been a
song you don't necessarily think it's
like an emotional song but you like cry
too anyways
i have been
belting exile
what's that the taylor swift song
i think i've seen this film before
and i didn't like the ending i don't
know what it's from your singing is not
bad yeah well is that my challenge by
the way to sing yeah yeah can we we need
better challenges by the way someone
brought dancing dancing was your
challenge dancing is so
boring faster can do it i'd want to do
it
great choreography again [ __ ] it's so
weird you're such a little talent thank
you we did bring a music player um we
have the stem player oh do we have to
dance for esther's birthday yesterday
no i was under the impression i was
getting a lap dance today from both of
you
happy birthday
i'm sorry i probably hurt your fake your
fake neck injury
who got the stem player
pete and george own them they just
walked because pete and george are rich
they're just pretending to be poor
what they're two hundred dollars and
it's not that much just say it pete say
i'm rich say it out loud
george pay him more because you're rich
tesla are the stem player and i chose
the stem player you guys the tesla is so
[ __ ] good it's so good
i was listening to okay wait todd made
this observation he said i only like
duets
and i do cry to them i do get really
emotional when there's a duet i don't
know i need but you are such a twin i
know i think it's the twin thing being a
twin like
like some people can just be a twin and
be normal but for you you just took it
and you just
ruined it and it's subconscious too like
i don't even know it's just i'm so twin
i'm just accidentally in matching
outfits it just happens all the time i
don't even it's like just happening
i do wonder like because i growing up i
told you i've always been close friends
with twins always and growing up i was
the twins i was friends with when i was
really little like i was always so
jealous and would think like what was
that like
like to have someone do like you can
you're so close to them and you actually
had it and it slipped through my hands
and your crap
and i let it slip through my hands
all i can do is get to his wife and his
daughters i get as close as i can get i
would the cat won't have me i can't even
get a cat to like me i just my goal in
life is for your twin brother to one day
formally have a restraining order it's
so cool and it's like he loves you and
you guys but he's like i just it's for
our own safety he's like it's just never
felt uh equal it just never felt like
we need to have one day her twin brother
here but without her
if you can get him here i i would be if
you can get him on the phone please let
me know
i would love to just be there listen i
would love to hear his voice in real
time it's been so long
so i heard a rumor
that because it's my birthday i was
going to get lap dances
esther i think that we should save your
birthday dance for the live stream so
that let's choreograph and choreograph
something yes let's give you a good one
i want to wash my puss too a little bit
okay i'll definitely wear sweat
you know what makes me really sad i went
to when we were in new york i went to a
strip club alone how was it all by my
lonesome it was amazing
tell us about the girls no where i
bought myself
she didn't [ __ ] invite me yeah that
is a lie
did i not go to your room and i asked
you and carlos hey guys i
uh i'm heading out there no you did go
out that's true no it's totally i was
not gonna go out and we all know that
right they were cuddled in i know that
carlos was watching his basketball but
i went to this place that was
recommended to me by one of schultz's uh
producers it was called the box and it
was just a burlesque um spot the box is
the funniest name for a strip club i
know that's what
kind of that was the allure i was like
this is a genius [ __ ] yeah
so i was just gonna go to like rick's
cabaret or something i was like the box
sounds interesting but it was just
burlesque and i got myself a little
table um and yeah it was kind of lonely
but kind of fun i've gone to a strip
club alone before it's super fun
right you guys need to get twins okay i
have to do stuff like this i got a
brother
i got a brother who won't take my call i
got i got a brother to call nonstop but
what's really sad is drinking alone
that's what i didn't like because then i
have to go back to my hotel room now i'm
just like nauseous fisting yourself
you're horny and drunk yeah yeah
it's so true throw a little sprinkle a
little okay the faucet on your back to
have let's can we clarify something for
a second
nobody
nobody
fists themselves ah pull it up carlos
100 yeah esther we're crazy esther you
are a weird brood because you're a dirty
[ __ ] i know you are
you're a [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] what is
this just because i didn't drink i just
don't know your arms are not long enough
are yours yeah
there's
also yeah my i am a knuckle dragger i
have really long arms i have lebron
wingspan
i can throat myself this is showing us
how you have to sign like a thing yeah
that's a yak soap what'd you find
yeah esther c i mean endlessly videos
this that's what this thing is you've
got a lot to bend over okay
this live stream is gonna be great there
she's to get there carlos is like i
don't want to do this at work there we
go esther do you not call that fisting
i want to i don't want to certainly i
don't like watching because i really i
cannot watch porn without getting turned
on
wow good for you [ __ ] congratulations
happy birthday esther
she could pull the whole like all three
of the bananas out to give them to us
from that [ __ ] ass
oh my god i was so proud of some of
these girls i know wait esther i i
randomly i brought some presents from
the road
for you oh and for everyone
they're not that many i just people
might be all these people people give me
all these presents or like annie
subconsciously knew it was my birthday
like something weird is going on
okay and she with the auritzia bag it is
i know i want to remind you of your
trauma
oh god it's okay
wait i don't know what is on the bottom
there something spelled out okay so this
is spilled that is not what you wanted
from when annie's about to hand boobs
moogs
gave these she said dearest slugs i know
you don't smoke but maybe this sluggy
ashtray could be part of the set kalila
liked a pic of it and i peed myself so i
also make jewelry and included a few
pieces for each of you you can give me
these gimme gimme gimme gimme look how
cool this is ah so good that's so bad i
almost kept it but i was like that's so
rude is this for me this is for the set
oh and then this is for coco
coco
green's my favorite color
there's nothing
she hands them all out
george people are like really pushing
the mushroom thing for you i think it's
time wait why a mushroom oh they want
yeah i think listen you guys inside
these earrings are papaya seeds that's
so cool in honor of tiger belly like
nosotros papaya oh
how cute is this snake
and then she gave me a pearl necklace
like i already have one
do i put it over my other pearl necklace
esther gave it to me
for her birthday that's so you and then
i get them all the time i have to
remember to bring them you guys if you
gave me stuff and i forgot i'm so sorry
it's somewhere
i love this thank you moobs we should
have a p.o box and the boys have to go
through it first oh those are cute
that's cool some girls gave me them off
of her okay and then i got this shirt
which i honestly i'm like i want to keep
it but i think it's more coco
in dc they went shopping for me and they
found this it's so cool the buck stops
here it's right next to the white house
look at the bottom oh i like that is
that a vintage shirt yeah they went and
shopped for it
they got it for me but i i don't know if
my pets wear it until i get my pizza
wait um show us to first because her and
i have the same t-shirts no you can you
can it's your birthday i want you to
start with it and then i'll see you
sisterhood of the traveling shirt
because i don't want to give it away for
for real for real shirt oh and it's
really soft and i tell you more i have
to find there's also i have to find out
who did it there's this picture um
someone drew of randy with heart glasses
on and i couldn't bring it for set i
have it in my house
and it's so cute but i'll plug her this
was from an artist at a show in
nashville she painted this with me and i
know so i think it's so cute the bubbles
and stuff too i know she did such a good
job last night at the comedy store
i could not believe how many slugs were
there i was like this is what annie's
always talking about it was like
kind of crazy weird yeah it's weird
because
i'll say this because i've been going
the comedy store for
literally 13 years and now it's so
abundantly different all of a sudden
because of this podcast people are
showing up to see me and it was not like
that i'm like gonna cry it's like it's
different it's not like okay so there's
two ways you can look at it it's like
our egos we're excited because we're
successful and stuff like that but it's
i swear to god it's not that it's like
there is a [ __ ] vibe and a connection
and it's crazy and it's growing and
people are bringing like new people that
have never watched the show to the
stand-up shows they're coming they're
liking the show they're going and
watching it it's really cool well
there's you know what it is it's this
overall
connection like these people
like relate to us and like there's a
connection there and so i know that like
when i see meet a slug at a show it's
like they relate to what we say i don't
know it just feels really good it's
really good it's a feeling that they've
already accepted who you are
yeah that's that's why you we feel like
because we've we've dumped all of our
deepest darkest on here right like
horrible thing that and they they
somehow still love you so you feel an
automatic safety around um these people
i feel that and i think it's like a vice
versa versa two thing where it's like
the fact that they're getting to feel
like relief in the things that they've
been ashamed of where it's like no no no
baby
you're one of us you're just yes do you
know what i do think that that is
accidentally one of the themes of this
show which i might have brought this up
on schultz i'm not sure but like
i got a message
that was like
you have taught me self-acceptance and i
was like i never thought about that but
because we are so radically
accepting of our own flaws and we are
open and share them that is what's
showing other people like you can be
[ __ ] up and it's fine i mean and it's
kind of funny the fact that we're
laughing so hard about this [ __ ] is
getting pounded by our teachers
our cow drug counselors and [ __ ] is like
crazy yeah you know what i was just
thinking about there was i was just had
this flashback i was listening to this
music and it was these two songs and i
had met this british guy when i was in
was it a michael mcdonald song no it was
they were uh masamura muramasa or
something i don't know
something i don't know but uh i met this
guy this british guy when i was in new
orleans years ago and we were like
making out at the bar
and then i thought i might like him we
both lived in brooklyn and i like went
stayed at his house one night and i
didn't like him and i didn't [ __ ] i
remember realizing that was the first
time i didn't [ __ ] someone
that i
had like set out to [ __ ] but my body
chose not to when i didn't do it i
usually would just be like bang them
anyway because i felt like rude or
whatever and i'm just thinking like how
do you learn these lessons earlier like
how do you teach like girls younger i
mean some people just have self-esteem i
think it's different now for sure the
girls are getting more information
because i think that they have girls
like us that are like hey do not go down
the route i did you know let's be
transparent i know i have those talks
with jules and i she feels very safe
telling me everything is open
and if she has a question or a weirdness
about something she'll be like hey is it
weird when this this is it weird if i do
and i'm very open yeah um
so i think i we didn't have that yeah i
just it never occurred to me you know
what it is because it's i to say like
teaching
women to say no and girls to say no more
is kind of like a good way to put it but
it's deeper than that because i think
for me it was but i didn't even the
concept of boundaries was so
mind-blowing even like a year ago to me
in any way seriously think about our
friendship did i not understand
boundaries right seriously like
i mean for real like i didn't get it and
then
i realized what the term holding space
meant i always just thought it was a
nice way of saying like i'm here for you
but it's not like holding space means
you're present to hear someone without
judgment right just like what are you it
doesn't matter if they're telling you
horrible things about cheating on their
spouse or whatever whatever it's like
i'm not here to judge you i'm literally
just going to listen and be patient and
that's being strong in yourself to be
able to do that where you're not making
what they're saying about you right the
worst thing is giving unsolicited advice
to someone who just wants to be heard
unsolicited advice is a form of what did
i hear
abuse probably
like criticism it is yeah i've caught
myself doing that today and with that
you probably should wear stripes
even on your birthday
i will commend myself i think i am good
at holding space for people i feel like
i'm a good person to come to if you
don't want to be judged yeah i'll listen
and i will i i only share my own secrets
you're good at boundaries you are so
good at holding space yesterday this is
my real birthday present but
what you are saying
what you it's like self like okay so to
even get to the point of boundaries i
had to like realize i really hated
myself like deep down in a way that i
never even let myself i was just go go
going so i wasn't i'm getting so like
yeah i was like uh uh-uh i was squirting
everywhere i wish
now
um but like i
was not um even like staying still
enough to like get like real with the
fact that i really
had a belief in myself that i [ __ ]
sucked and like didn't deserve things so
boundaries made no sense to me so then
once i got to that i was like oh
boundaries are so easy
wow it's so easy and it's for you it's
not for the other person it's not to
control the other person which is what
i'm learning now through boundaries it's
just yeah it's just what you need but i
understand like it does sound like a
thing that you would tell other people
this is my boundary but it's actually
you're right it's not that it's like
this is it's like all up here for you
because you can't control other people
no and like when i like whenever i've
blocked people like i blocked a couple
of my ex-boyfriends
on instagram stuff it's not like for
them to see i blocked them or for them
yeah
it has nothing to do with them it's
really just like i just don't want to i
just want to cut that connection off so
i can heal that and protect your energy
yeah yeah i
i'm dealing with something similar like
that in my life and
it's hard to
cut it off cut off communication with
someone it's really hard for me and i'm
like really trying to hold firm but it's
not easy yeah because it gets easier
over time yeah i think the initial part
of like you know we just said get so
used to having that person sort of
buzzing around us or whatever right but
once you
and and there's a pain it's almost like
a breakup but then you just it just gets
easier and then you realize over time
like oh that was the right move i did
that for myself and then all that space
and time you can fill up with something
good yeah yeah and i think it's good for
them yeah it is yeah you know
and
you know if there's a friendship to be
mended down the road you would have
initiated that you were the person that
initiated that you actually did
something really nice for them as well
to give them time to reflect on whatever
yeah and that's how i feel like the
quote that i keep thinking of is
detached with love it's like
we're detaching but there's love there
right because if you're angry you're
still attached
exactly
it's true
and it's
the most attached you are is when you
are angry yeah when you are feeling that
deep resentment that when you want to
lash out at somebody that is when you're
most tightly bound to them yeah because
you're taking up so much that person's
taking out so much of your space i was
like i was i think i said this on here
before but that the girl who stole my
mall okay okay like she like [ __ ] me
over and i'm this victim of her and she
does horrible thing and she told the
cops i was a liar and it was like the
sheer horror of my best friend doing
that all the stuff
i like up until that episode was still
mad at this girl and the truth is like
maybe what she did was bad maybe it
wasn't who knows why she did it
but um
i was mad at a 16 year old i was mad at
a 16 year old girl as a grown-ass woman
i was still mad at her wow and then i
was thinking like when i kept thinking
about my teacher who was sold to me he
had he was a white guy with dreads i
kept like bringing him with me i was
like i kept starting when i was starting
to really heal it i was i would imagine
myself when you know when you check
yourself out in the reflection when
you're walking down the street and
there's obviously another person in an
office that's seeing you yes
you can't see them and they're just
judging you i would do that and i would
always imagine that i'm i'm bringing
this like dreaded man with me are you
sorry i'm just pulling yeah and it
helped me stop doing it i know that i
was like dragging him into each day of
my life thinking about it upset about it
and not that it's okay that he [ __ ]
assaulted me or anything but it's not
mine it really isn't yours and i my
whole identity was like it is just
something that like happened to us but
it has zero to do with our constitution
who what we're
when you have like a bruised ego or a
bad self image of yourself
that stuff like attaches to you because
yeah in fact you know what i had to
break a friendship recently with someone
i'd known since childhood because every
time he spoke to me he spoke to me and
this like described me
as as if i was still a 19 year old drunk
which i was i was a horrible drunk late
teens early 20s probably a terrible
person but anytime he describes me to
other people like oh yeah that's just
kalaila she's crazy always just like
very in a very dismissive way
a place you're not at like hey dude i'm
37 years old literally 20 years have
passed like i've done the work i've made
amends how about you stop treating me
like the dumb drunk 19 year old and he
could not get past that and he's like oh
i'm just joking but that joke would just
continually come up and i'm like you
know what we're done here that's so
smart and aware of you because it's like
i've also had that experience where
someone's belief system about me
that will brainwash you into believing
the things that they say about you and
so i had a person in my life who would
always make a joke that i was stupid
and i it's like years went by and i woke
up one day and i'm like oh i've believed
that i've been stupid for the last
couple years and i like went to therapy
even i don't call her stupid
but stupid is such a mean word yeah yeah
my mom says it a lot but it's just like
but it's like [ __ ] really i don't think
i know anyone's stupid really
stupid everyone's smart at their own
thing you have to be careful because if
someone is a has a strong opinion of you
and they're always letting you know it
like it'll you'll brainwash yourself
into believing it but another step
when you were a kid and people said that
stuff to you and your brain was still
absorbing things and sponging things in
the things they said are now your voice
in your own head that are calling you
fat or calling you this or
you know like that's
so that's the voice you got to work on
too it was like
not even the outside [ __ ] the [ __ ] that
got in there when you were little we i
think we should like
decide
what are the beliefs about ourselves
that we want it to be like let's design
it for ourselves
well that's hypnosis too yeah you decide
your beliefs and then you instill them
you get yourself into like a
as a state where your subconscious is
like relaxed enough to take it in and
then you
just [ __ ] penetrate i will say why
this works
i know you guys don't think that you
have hypnotized me but in the year that
i've been around you guys like you
always you guys always like gassing me
up and saying kala you're pretty you're
hot like i've sort of
embodied those compliments and i think
that i've never felt better about myself
because i think when you guys first met
me i was very like oh but i'm so this
and i'm so fat and i still have those
moments but i think that you girls
really sort of like pushed me to
like now when i walk past and i get a
reflection
of myself i'm like oh my god i am so
pretty i haven't been she's pretty
inside typing like she is pretty look at
her
but i wasn't able to say that to myself
even like as short as like two years ago
where now i'm like oh it is good to
surround yourself with people who
make you feel that way because i've been
telling that stupid voice like you said
has been you know reciting this false
narrative about myself for so long and
it'll go back every time well yeah
because my mom was always like my mom
was like you can't say you're pretty be
humble be humble be humble you can't say
that out loud i'm like maybe you can
maybe yeah you can yeah that's how like
it is now but yeah when we were growing
up
it was like not cool to be you're
conceited yeah although i do remember
once like
one of the popular girls i was hanging
out with her and she said you know you
were there
[Laughter]
and she's like are you conceited and i
was like why and she's like i am
i was like
what a renegade but the word conceited
was a really popular word when we were
growing up right she's so conceited it
was a negative i'm like wait a second
what do you mean like good self as well
it's such a confusing thing too because
ego and self-esteem i'm i i'm not even
kidding i've been like trying to figure
out the difference between because it's
like
because you want to have high
self-esteem but you don't want to
because the judging ourselves on whether
this is what i said about the yoga what
i was thinking in yoga it's like if we
judge ourselves on like being pretty or
ugly it's like our body will change yeah
it's like it's just like loving yourself
because the frequency is love and then
you can't be mad at you can't be like
throwing hate at other people because
that's
coming from your love frequency so i
think that the difference between ego
and self-esteem it's like let's say
there's a job you want and you don't get
it why are you jerking it off i don't
know
but you felt it too and then you also
press like you're on jeopardy
you dropped it off and then you push the
tip
that um what is let's say you don't get
the job
your ego would be like [ __ ] them like oh
this they [ __ ] suck they made a mistake
but if you just start a person with
self-esteem i think you'd be like well i
know i could have done it and done a
great job but it's not this one it's not
the one for me yeah it's like the next
thing that's like my think how i just
yeah i don't know my mind is being blown
i have like you know i do that i watch
listen to the guy jim thornton's podcast
and stuff and i every time i listen to
that or marry lou my um
hypnotist like whenever i'm like feeling
away i always just click on one of their
videos and it's always like
the video it's weird it's like whatever
video i need to hear like randomly i'll
just click on one
but it's all like i keep hearing all
this attachment stuff and it's cool
i love it we're self-improving in 2022
we're trying that that is we're in it
we're doing it it's done yeah which is
already done
well
this has been the weirdest birthday i've
ever had what have you what did you
learn on your birthday esther i learned
that we are honestly that we're all very
in tune
and like on the path of self-improvement
and i love that like i think that we
have our slugs come here and be with us
and we say really
rotten things and are really weird but i
like that we're also circling back to
like getting better and being good
people and it makes me feel good so
that's
what i learned the pile of manure with
the flour growing oh like the roast that
grew on concrete
tupac shakur um slugs thank you so much
for being here and as always please
subscribe to this channel and
uh come see our live stream
momenthouse.com
trash tuesday that is coming up very
soon and it's going to be chaotic and
ruin our lives
[Music]
you